we want more power for the European
Parliament we want in more Europe and
not less Europe we want to strengthen
Europe and not to destroy Europe on the
MFF we are in favor a change from 1.1 to
1.3 we are in favor on resources also
immigration is an important point for
the European Parliament European
Parliament approved the reform of Dublin
rules
we want a decision by European Council
on this and yesterday today at the
center of the debate there are two key
points brexit and Venezuela
this is important to know you are ideas
on the future of the European Union we
know the position of the European
Commission
there is the position of European
Parliament of course there are the
position of different member states and
now it's important to know the position
of villain premier the floor thank you
we record ok anybody did may I remind
you that now is the time to submit
requests for catch the eye which will
follow the opportunity to submit your
names for casually I will end as soon as
the premise or speech is finished
president of the Commission members of
the Parliament my warm regards from very
cold Finland I was in the northern part
of Finland where I am living last
weekend and there was minus 30 decrease
and about 1 meters snow but this it's a
pleasure
so this is a real winter it's a pleasure
to be here today the European Parliament
has done excellent work in the recent
very challenging circumstances
forward-looking discussions about
European Union are essential for two
reasons in order to reach the vision of
the Rome declaration we need to discuss
how we achieve sufficient unity to make
decisions and implement them second we
must be paid to discover each other's
priorities in the use
and budget EU countries became familiar
to me as enterpreneur through sister
companies around Europe in my thirties I
remember traveling to meet the CEO of
the big French company in the plane I
read a kite book my wife had burrowed
from library to me I said it said that
never ask anything about the family when
you are in a business meeting with a
Frenchman
once I arrived a dinner meeting the CEO
was there with her wife and daughter the
first question to me was tell me about
your family I understood that we
Europeans get along and we have more in
common than we may think already in
1920s a founder of InnoCentive party
Suntory algea wrote that for the sake of
peace in europe the continent should
consider leading its politics towards
United States of Europe he even
mentioned a common currency he was a
piano in many respects also in this one
choosing international cooperation and
generating peace and economic
development have been a guiding line for
Finland dear friends in recent years we
have been given a lesson in populist in
Europe we have seen where it leads when
the solution for complex issues are
provided by simplifying matters in the
end nobody takes responsibility there
was a case in the United Kingdom and the
result is there for all to see not only
practice it but populism hits the EU
from several fronts setbacks in rule of
law freedom of press and women rights
News we would not expect to hear in 30
21st century Europe how can we how can
you promote its common values in its
external policies if it can't make it
within European Union common values such
as democracy rule of law have been
foundation of the of the Europe's
freedom Security and Prosperity there's
a suit unites the Member States it's
essential to preach Europeans in the
internal divisions at the same time we
can't be any there can't be any
compromises on the rule of law Finland
warmly welcomes Commission's MFF rule of
law proposal I am convinced that there
is a way to establish well-balanced
mekinese till to this end mr. president
dear members of the Parliament the most
important cornerstone that Finland's
position towards developing EU as well
as monetary union is to respect what we
what has been agreed and the efficient
implementation we we strongly support
the kind of European Union that achieves
its credibility throughout concrete
actions in 2015 my government started in
the situation where public deficit was
nearly to 3.5%
relative to GDP we made to present
painful savings related to GDP we made
reforms improving public finances like
social and health care reform and
pension reform the internal devaluation
of 4% was made for pool
employment and crowds we agreed with the
unions about salary freeze and cuts an
extension of 24 hours in annual working
time and a decrease of Social Security
contribution of employees to name a few
as you might guess this list was not
very popular however now after three
years the public deficit is covered the
state budget is in balance and the
employment rate is the highest in 30
years with that said the idea of solving
these kind of problems with permanent
fiscal transfers is unacceptable
unacceptable for us the best insurance
against economic shocks is balanced
budget and low debt ratio many times
during these years I have come back to
quote by jean-claude Juncker we all know
what to do
we just don't know how to get re-elected
after we have done it in my Bart I am
testing this in practice in upcoming
elections in April let's see my point is
that this part of the risk the member
state states must be capable of making
decisions and implementing them
efficient implementing is absolutely the
best method to respond the current and
future challenges we need implementation
of the single market and R&D and
innovations implementation of the
internal and external security policies
implementation of migration policies
policies implementation of climate
policies better implementation is the
best tool in fighting against populism
and in increasing
citizens confidence in European Union
ladies and gentlemen Finland holds the
EU presidency in the second half of this
year next I point out some areas that
will be in the agenda during our
presidency there are also topics where
EU must be able to work more closely
together and walk the talk efficiently
I'll start from mff that is a key
implementation tool for the future EU
policy in Finland Finland spewed the
overall level of mff should be as close
as possible to current relative share
the focus needs to be in the areas where
u is is best placed to deliver like on
migration security single market
innovations digitalization and climate
we also see that there is an E need to
reallocate funding on rural development
within the budget common aquaculture
policy helps to provide affordable and
safe food to the citizens it ensures
that farmers can make a reasonable
living and promote jobs in farming and
food industry at the same time the
cohesion policy creates more balanced
development between and inside the
Member States I am confident that we
will be able to find balanced compromise
between traditional policy areas and new
challenges
I am also confident that we can do it
during the Finnish presidency
second we need my crescent policy with
comprehensive approach first the root
causes of migration must be addressed
more efficiently in addition to
development cooperation and humanitarian
aid trade and investments are needed to
create jobs and sustainable development
we must also work hard to enhance more
effective return policy the internal
aspect of migration is in our own hands
we should manage migration increasing
increasingly throughout direct
resettlement from the refugee camps
this would mean smaller pressure on EU
'the external borders and less smuggling
at the same time management of our
external borders should be reinforced
there is also need to proceed with most
complicated pollak political issues like
mechanism on solidarity during crisis
it's crucial we agree on this in advance
not in the middle of crises like we did
in 2015
thirdly security and defense cooperation
is also important and need to be
intensified Finland has been actively
calling for ambe's progress in security
and defense cooperation also together
with France now we welcome the progress
creation of European defence fund and
pesco have been also been steps in right
direction now we should concrete on
implied implementation and reaching
results the EU has also strengthened its
capacity for countering hybrid threats
the Europe center for countering hybrid
threats in Helsinki contribute
the preparedness of NATO and EU
countries against these threats I want
to thank the 19 participating countries
from which 16 are EU members for strong
commitment I also welcome all the rest
Member States to join that Center fourth
we must improve the single market we are
the best single market in the world in
addition to innovations and trade this
is our best way to create new jobs a lot
of potential exists especially in
services and digital products improving
the situation is fully in our own hands
I urge to find a common mindset to pass
those 35 proposals which are still under
negotiations looking ahead I hope that
future Commission will take more
holistic approach where single market
digitalization industrial policy and
external competitiveness are better in
the length we should aim at
forward-looking Road Statuary this
includes among others data mobility and
artificial intelligence it's also
important to enhance the competitiveness
by implementing the principles of EU
social pillar it's for instance crucial
to promote equality in working life and
to enhance education level all citizens
fifth trade policy is also Cruz crucial
for use competitiveness and new job jobs
in respect of free trade agreements I am
pleased with the latest achievements
with Japan Vietnam Singapore Mexico and
Canada and with fast progress to ongoing
negotiations however it's harmful if the
big players continue to build trade
walls we must do everything to prevent
or tear down such walls especially from
the view view of smaller countries the
damage would be further we must respect
and obey the common rules on trade and
finally EU must take a lead or in
climate change actions
the report on international panel on
climate change again reminded us the
threat posed by climate change to life
on Earth we can't walk away from science
beside a threat
I see many possibilities in this global
challenge as an engineer I tend to think
in a solution and technology based way I
am sure that as the world moves towards
low-carbon development we are in the
front line in developing new
technologies ambitious climate policy
will also support our job creation here
in Europe we need measures in three
fronts co2 emissions carbon sinks and
new technologies last week
Finland hosted fill not climate Nordic
climate meeting in Helsinki Nordic
countries gave a promise to rise the
level of the climate ambition by 2020
the Nordic countries want to catalyze
meditation efforts to limit the global
warming to 1.5 decrease also in the
roundtable discussions in the Finnish
Parliament 8 Finnish bodies set an
objective that EU should achieve carbon
neutrality before 2050 that requires
tightening at the emission reduction
application for 2032 to at least 55
percent of the 1990 level the EU
emissions trading system is most cost
efficient way to reduce greenhouse gas
emissions
Finland aims to renew the system so that
the price of the emission allowances
guide kites operators towards emission
reductions more quickly and efficiently
we have proposed that new sectors
as heating and cooling of buildings
should be integrated into ETS
furthermore we have accelerate the
transition towards circular and pyar
economy the Bioeconomy action plan
should be implemented without delay as a
small detail my government decided not
to give any EU Presidency gifts instead
we use the money to compensate the
emission caused by air traveling through
during the presidency second we need to
increase carbon sinks we have four
billion hectares of forest and five
billion hectares of fields
it has surprised me how much more
agricultural fields can find co2 if we
made some changes in farming practices
we have 100 so-called carbon farmers
testing new practices in Finland oceans
and carbonate minerals can lock down
carbon dioxide dioxide as well we also
need to plant more forests in Africa
alone 2 million hectares of forests are
lost every year that is equivalent of
slovenia's total land area as FAO state
of of the world forests report says the
world response to climate change must
focused more on forests one concrete
step we should use in --use external
funding is increased global carbon sinks
Finland has proposed an EU African
forest fund forest investments would
maximize the impact on climate and ruler
shops in Africa third news
technology must be adapted even now we
have the technical capacity to capture
co2 from the air and convert it to other
products EU needs to invest in research
and development and better exploit the
huge potential of science technology and
innovation in this area we also have to
think an innovative way new incentives
and market driven methods to ensure that
also carbon sinks will be increased my
strong message is that we have to do
more and faster we must reduce emissions
increase carbon sinks and adapt new
technologies to capture co2 from the air
or directly from the emission sources
the European fellows after the European
Parliament elections the European
Council needs to agree on ambitious and
comprehensive agenda
besides climate change our focus should
be on crowd and security in as in
addition rule of law issues will remain
central this is my call for more united
european union that is capable and come
for concrete actions implementation and
peering responsibility this means
response responsibility for ourselves
for people and surrounding close to us
for economy and for the planet let's
remember that we we are all here to
safeguard the better future for the
youth and generations to come for our
sake and for our common future
we all need determined efficient and
united European Union I can't hide a
highlight more the importance of
getting things done this is why I have
underlined the word implementation in
the speech so many times democratic
democratic forces of Europe will win
back the trust of the people by making
decisions and implementing them at home
and also here in Brussels thank you
thank you very much Prime Minister
Savita for your speech in front of the
European Parliament the next speaker is
the President of the European Commission
jean-claude Juncker you have the floor
Monsieur president president Prime
Minister ladies and gentlemen here came
myself a very pleased to be here in the
presence of you ha my friend the Prime
Minister Finland Finland became a member
of the European Union in 1995 and as
fate would have it I became Prime
Minister the same day and you know
sometimes that's the way Europe works
and I have always said that Finland as
of the very first day of accession acted
as if it had been a founder member as if
Finland had always been there and
certain founder members would do well by
taking Finland as an example and by
adopting similar behavior left since
Finland has been a member it has always
shown that it has an ability to listen
Finland and its respective governments
know how to listen and Finland here's
what it hears doesn't just listen it
takes note
and implements it we've seen this
through all Prime Minister's Pavel
opponent for example my friend Jay
Riecke
here it's a bit of a Finnish day three
Finnish Prime Minister's dealing with
the Commission it's perhaps rare but
it's certainly useful the third Finnish
presidency is looming on the horizon it
will be a presidency which it will be of
a particular nature unique nature
because the presidency will come at a
time following the European elections
prior to the nomination of a new
president of the Parliament sorry the
Commission the council central bank so
it will be a period where we'll have to
see a great deal of strength coming from
the presidency country and we've seen
this from Finland during the course of
their two first Presidency's between
Finland and Commission the relations
couldn't be better
we are working in full conscience
that has been the case when we were
establishing the security and defence
mechanism that is the case when it comes
to energy and climate and this is the
case when it comes to developing the
connectivity infrastructure in the water
region of Finland I will in the name of
the Commission like to make use of the
Finnish presidency in order to develop
the Arctic damage this is an important
issue because the Arctic region is
warming twice the global average rate of
temperature increase Finland is holding
for the time being the presidency of the
Arctic Council I was discussing with my
friend you are
I was in Finland in November the idea to
call you the Finnish presidency a summit
of the Arctic counts because I think
that we have to make sure that the
Arctic region is moving to the top of
the European agenda how about you finish
the presidential boost but the finished
presidency has a great deal to do
besides my desert autumn would be a
deepening of the economic and monetary
union during the course of the finished
presidency completing the banking union
the capital markets union and finally
put the final touches to those the focal
points of what is set out for the
Finnish presidency will see the median
term financial planning it's quite a
tough job of work and we've got our work
cut out there but they finished
presidency can depend on the Commission
to help them and make sure that progress
is made during the Finnish presidency so
that the European Council meeting in
October this year we can reach a
conclusion the multi-annual financial
framework is something that has to be
sorted out and decided on this year
otherwise we're going to lose valuable
time to develop the programs to
implement those programs as well I would
be grateful to the Finnish presidency as
well if in the framework of the
financial multi-annual financial
framework but also in deepening the
economic and monetary union that they
would take on board the proposals from
the Commission
to deal with an instrument to strengthen
structural reforms and a stabilisation
instrument to counter external shocks
the last European Council meeting
approached this topic very tentatively
and people out in Europe expect Europe
to act so that any crises that may come
up in the future will be dealt with
better than previous ones I would like
to thank the Finnish government because
they are one of the government's in
Europe who have taken the investment
plan that European myself have put
together and paid a great deal of
attention to it eight billion euros in
investments to date have been affected
thanks to this plan in Finland it would
be good if everybody did as you do and
all I can do is wish you all the best
for April all the best for the Finnish
presidency please carry on she's on I'll
if there are any other members of
parliament who want to register for
catch the eye they should sue so
immediately because I am going to be
closing the electronic registration for
catch the eye the next speaker is the
chair of the EPP Manfred Weber and mr.
Commission president mr. prime minister
pillar welcome here in the European
Parliament and you are here in the
crucial moment of time the people have a
say for the future of your country in
April and Europe in May so it is